[Music]
someone replaced our moon with a disco
ball
how could you turn the moon into a
classic disco ball
how much more light would this new moon
reflect
and would it actually turn the earth
into one giant nightclub
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we replaced our moon with a
disco ball
you know no matter how bright it seems
the moon doesn't produce any light of
its own instead it gets its shine
reflecting about 10 percent of the
incoming sunlight that hits it
and thanks to the uneven surface of the
moon
that light is reflected at many
different angles
if we made the moon more like a disco
ball
we could change the way it reflects
light entirely
disco balls cast dazzling beams of light
all over a room
they do that thanks to their many
mirrored tiles
now imagine a disco ball the size of our
moon in our night sky
would it spark an amazing rave back on
earth
or would it literally ignite fires
thanks to one dream the real party is
back here on earth yeah the folks who
brought you the great courses plus are
back bigger and better than ever as one
dream and they have even more
mind-blowing educational experiences
ready to share with you i've been
watching the first few minutes of the
universe a documentary exploring what
happened in the milliseconds after the
big bang
every second mattered when the building
blocks of life came together and now
every second matters if you want to take
advantage of this deal to get access to
documentaries how to's and thoroughly
researched academic content made by the
most engaging experts around
visit onedrive.com
what if show click on the link in the
description below and start your free
trial today
keep this party going and start
expanding your
mind okay where would you even start
knocking the moon out of its orbit and
placing a giant disco ball in its place
could be quite problematic
so you could start with something a
little less dramatic like covering the
moon in mirror tiles
a disco ball has a radius of anywhere
between 10 to 183 centimeters
the moon however is bigger much bigger
it has a radius of about 1700 kilometers
making a disco ball that large would
require covering the moon's surface with
over 3 000 mirror tiles
and those wouldn't be your average
dressing room mirrors
these massive tiles would range in size
from 100 to 150 kilometers across
you'd have to create those giant mirrors
on earth and then deliver them all the
way to the moon
it would take you at least three days to
get them there and it's going to take a
few round trips
so it might be a good idea to ask nasa
or maybe the spacex team to help out
with robotic lunar missions while you'd
be preparing for the party of your
lifetime
okay now that all the mirror panels are
in place
wait
where did the moon go
[Music]
as anti-climactic as it sounds
once you turned the moon into our solar
system's own disco ball
you wouldn't see much from earth
the moon reflects so much sunlight
because the lunar surface is so uneven
this makes light bounce off in a chaotic
manner
the sunlight hits the moon at one angle
and then is scattered at different
angles
but now that the disco moon would have a
very even surface
the sunlight would get reflected at the
same angle it came in
you'd have to try very hard to see this
new variety of reflected moonlight from
earth
well what is that
now you'd need to find yourself at the
exact angle of the reflection
is anyone else seeing this that's it
based on the locations of the earth sun
and moon
these reflections would only hit the
earth every few months
what you'd witness would be more like an
extremely brief flash of light in the
sky
not quite the funky global ambience you
had in mind
okay well maybe you could take things up
a notch with a little creative
engineering
yeah instead of flat mirror tiles you
could use curved mirrors
these would reflect all the incoming
light into one point
this would certainly increase the
likelihood of the reflected light
reaching you back on earth but
it would come at a pretty grave cost
all that energy concentrated into a
single point could create a sunbeam
strong enough that it would cause havoc
wherever it hits
this could turn the moon into a death
star-like device of destruction
except in this case multiple beams of
light would wander over different parts
of the planet
anything in their path would ignite in
flames leaving behind nothing but
patches of scarred earth
it's the same effect as if you
concentrated sunlight with a magnifying
glass
only about a million times worse
now if the moon were no longer tidally
locked there would at least be the
upside of having reflections that could
move fast enough across the earth's
surface to avoid igniting everything
now despite the chaos of hyper-blazing
sunbeams you'd be lucky that the mirrors
don't reflect an enormous amount of uv
radiation toward earth
enough that it may burn you to a crisp
maybe the trick to getting the party
started would be to supply the disco
ball moon with some artificial light
from here on earth
for this you could try beaming lasers at
the moon
sure this light could reach the moon but
the odds of being able to see any of it
reflected back to earth would be
slim to none
as the laser beam traveled through
earth's atmosphere photons would scatter
in many directions
the chance that photons of light
launched from earth would reach one of
the moon's reflector panels would only
be one in 25 million and then those
photons would need to make the
uninterrupted journey back through our
atmosphere
the probability of that happening would
be an even more dismal one in 250
million
now that you're desperate for something
to impress people with you'd go to your
last ditch effort
wrapping the entire moon in aluminum
foil
if you managed to do this smoothly you
could make the moon around eight times
brighter than it is today
i mean it still may not have the
dazzling effect you were hoping for from
the get-go but if you crinkled that
aluminum foil up a bit you could get a
few small reflective glints like
bouncing off a glass or a watch
we're sorry that the party really never
kicked off the way you wanted it to but
if you really managed to cover the moon
in mirrors you'd at least be treated to
a truly stunning sight
it would almost be like catching sight
of a second earth in our own solar
system
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]